yeah long session for
especially the black players in these
games if they manage not to win their
games they're one they will fall loose
people are saying
is he winning play king of four another
chance for niels
what should we have done king d5 foreign
game yeah a very swanky game if he spots
it he has a minute oh
and he was already doing my closing
speech and 93 played just apparently
managed to actually throw it all away no
how rook at five was wrong yeah five is
not the
that is not the way
what was the way the way wasn't very
easy
the way apparently was to go rookie one
knight e6 94 and knight c6 i don't think
you can do that okay some random stuff
yeah absolutely and and some some other
quiet moves were also winning but yeah
this is now somehow a draw
i don't think there was much wrong with
just winning the pawn straight away
look more direct but this also should
force resignations that's probably yeah
pretty much yeah and yeah
resigns niels does win the game
after all first victory in the
tournament congrats to nils
what a roller coaster
yeah there's there's been some some
swings and
also potentially roundabouts in in this
game